well my first guest tonight is a
passionate advocate for free speech and
she also knows more than most about what
it's like to be trolled online I'd like
to say that Caitlyn Jenner joins me now
I think from Hollywood Caitlyn how are
you
you know what Pierce I'm doing just fine
actually very excited to see what's
going to happen to social media now that
uh Elon Musk is in control of Twitter I
think it's going to be very interesting
in the future actually if I could and
this is going to take a little while for
social media to kind of get used to this
the Elon Musk here it's kind of almost
like when Liv golf came in uh to the
golf world the PGA kind of had a
monopoly going here well social media
has had a monopoly on
um you know the far left and and finally
Elon Musk came in and he wants a free
speech platform for everybody the left
the right and I think it's going to be
good and I think it's going to really
shake up social media you look at Mark
Zuckerberg was reported last week he
lost like 100 million dollars or 100
billion dollars whatever it was and
value of meta because he's been so far
far left for so long and a voice for the
left
that people are leaving and going
someplace else so this is going to take
some time to figure out exactly how it's
going to work out but I think it's going
to be very good in the long run for
social media yeah I mean I completely
agree and I think Elon Musk you know
he's proven himself to be a a genius who
likes to challenge Orthodoxy in terms of
how we think whether it's electric cars
whether it's SpaceX is extraordinary uh
space company which does all these
Starling satellites as well you know and
now this I think he's the right guy
because as I keep trying to explain to
people he's not even someone who
identifies as right-wing or conservative
you know he's a Bernie Sanders fan he
spent most of his life actually
positioning himself politically to the
left and yet it's the people on the left
who have gone so far left in my opinion
that it makes people who are on the
center or maybe even slightly center
right look like they're far right by
comparison that's that's been the
problem
no Elon Musk I think is going to be very
good for Twitter I I have met him on a
couple of occasions
um actually I got a I'm into Aviation
and I got a private tour of SpaceX where
they uh down at Hawthorne where they
build the rockets and he gave me an hour
tour we sat in his office he was
wonderful
um and I think he's he is a big thinker
I mean when you say you're going to
start space company and you're going up
uh you know against NASA
that takes a lot you know it takes some
pretty big ones there and uh I think
he's going to do the same thing here the
first thing he's starting up with is
he's going to make it as a subscription
um
where he has Twitter blue uh I think one
of the reasons why when he first got in
and started looking into Twitter uh he
saw that there were so many accounts
that you couldn't verify and he wants to
be able to verify it so he's going to
put up for 19.95 you can get a verified
account on Twitter blue and I think
that's going to be very good you're
you're going to get rid of a lot of the
junk that's out there
um he's immediately started firing all
the top Executives in fact I think it
was today he completely fired the entire
Board of Twitter uh bringing his people
in actually he's bringing in a lot of
technical people from uh from Tesla and
he's going to shake this thing up I
think it's going to be
so interesting to watch and I think it's
going to be nothing but good you know
I've been on Twitter I've been Shadow
banned in fact interesting uh I was
Shadow banned the day it was announced
that I joined Fox News as a contributor
I immediately got it but it's funny it's
funny you say that you say that Caitlyn
because oddly I'd noticed over the last
few months my Twitter following uh
number had gone down quite slowly but
steadily for months and months and
months I was losing followers but in the
last two weeks since it looked like Elon
Musk was basically going to be taking it
over I've suddenly gained all the
followers I lost in two weeks now it
might be coincidence
it might be I don't know they were
taking away Bots or something like that
or it might just be that from the moment
it looked like Elon Musk was actually
going to run Twitter a lot of the people
doing this kind of Shadow Banning which
for people who don't know they put you
know stuff in the technology which
basically reduces the visibility of
people they perceive to be conservative
or maybe anti-woke or whatever it may be
certainly in my case it would be
anti-woke not conservative but I I smell
a rat here and I think you probably have
experienced similar stuff right
I've experienced the same thing you know
here's a little trivia
uh I broke a Guinness Book of World
Records on Twitter
when I came out and the guy was not on
Twitter when I came out uh was on the
cover of Vanity Fair
uh I immediately when that came out I
immediately opened up my Twitter account
and I broke the world record for a
broken set of Guinness Book of World
Records for the fastest to one million
followers
um Barack Obama had it at five hour five
hours and and like 20 minutes uh I did
it in four hours and uh two minutes from
zero to one million I would expect black
inside I would expect nothing else from
a Olympian gold medal champion
yes and so
um yeah I've been with Twitter for a
very long time and yes I've been Shadow
banned I have also noticed in the last
couple of weeks things have started to
change uh your amount of engagements is
going up
um I think it's honestly I think this is
going to be good not just for Twitter
but
social media okay if you were Elon and
you're looking at all the problems of
Twitter and I think we all know what
they are there are way too many
Anonymous Bots and they can influence I
think political uh issues in a
manipulative way which could potentially
then manipulate votes and therefore
elections I think that remains a big
concern also this the amount of abuse
you know racism harassment death threats
and so on is still there I see it you
know every now and again where it's ugly
head yeah
um where for you where is the life and
it's a very interesting debate this
about where the line is
for free speech where is free speech and
where for you who's been on the subject
of a lot of abuse and trolling where for
you is the line that gets crossed
well first of all I think that's in Elon
musk's hands right now and the people
that he brings in he has to bring in
some really good competent people to be
able to run Twitter because obviously
hate speech shouldn't be anywhere
um it shouldn't be online it shouldn't
be anywhere and there is that fine line
between hate speech and something that's
either true or maybe not quite as you
know true it's almost like for me it's
almost like I get a lot of jokes about
me I've been roasted in this and
everything and there is that fine line
between a funny joke that is really true
okay and a funny joke that is like
hateful to me that always I don't want
hateful jokes against me I want funny
jokes against me and you can use me and
I love as good a laugh as anybody but
it's going to be the same thing with
Twitter
um where is that fine line and I think
that he's going to have to have very
competent people in there to be able to
find out where that fine line is well
it's interesting you mentioned comedy
because he he actually tweets it comedy
is legal again oh yeah and I I responded
by tweeting back two laughing emojis and
a thumbs up which he then he then likes
very quickly so I and being liked by
Elon Musk on Twitter at the moment is a
bit like getting a Papal Blessing from
the pope if you're a Catholic
um you know it's not the ultimate
validation um and it shows of course his
only incredible engagement in Twitter I
mean he's all over it he reads
everything he sees everything he's
firing out tweets
I don't know how he does it the guy's
got a million things going on in his
life you know he's sending Rockets up to
space he's uh you know developing the
electric car which nobody said they
could really do and do it right and he
didn't still Tesla's the best electric
car on the market SpaceX uh is just
killing the only way uh any you know
astronauts can get to the space station
is now SpaceX NASA doesn't have any way
to get him there right so he's done an
amazing job but I think he'll do the
same thing with with Twitter it's going
to take a little time to work it out but
I think Elon Musk is really good at
getting
good people in the right place I agree
and if they're not working out he's
afraid he's not he's not you know afraid
to fire himself what would you do write
people in place he said today if he had
a I think he had a dime or a dollar for
everyone he's uh asked him what he's
going to do about Donald Trump he'd be
very rich which of course he's already
very rich he's got 235 billion dollars
but what would you do about Donald Trump
would you let him back on the platform
oh of course yeah why it's a free speech
platform now of course I would of course
I would you know what it's interesting
how the left is already starting to come
after him just uh on uh what was it just
today uh of course a is Senator Chris
Murphy a Democrat from Connecticut okay
on this Monday uh said that they have to
review Twitter because
um
um for the committee of foreign
investment why because the Saudis a lot
of people don't know this the Saudis
have big been been big investors in
Twitter for many many years I think they
hold about
1.89 uh billion dollars in investment in
Twitter most people don't know that but
now all of a sudden the left's going to
come after and say hey we have to check
out these Investments
Saudi Arabia's been around for a long
time with Twitter they're the number two
uh stockholder behind Elon Musk but the
left's going to take their shots
um I think Elon musk's a very sharp guy
I mean my argument about
Trump has been from the start of this is
if you're going to ban Donald Trump you
can't then allow as they've allowed
Vladimir Putin to retain his Twitter
account Taliban leaders the supreme
leader of Iran there's no consistency
there right you know you cannot allow
people like that to have accounts and
say Donald Trump should be banned in my
in my opinion it's not a question of
being right or left or any of these
things it's a question of balance and
consistency and I do think the one thing
Elon Musk is going to do he's going to
bring in a kind of a a group of people
from all walks of life all political
Persuasions and they're going to be the
ones who form a consensus about who
should be bad because there are some
people who I think probably should be
bad you know if you're going to be a
spewing you know racism or stuff which
endangers people's lives I would say
Alex Jones for example would be one
example to me where by spewing his lies
about Sandy Hook and imperiling the
lives of the relatives of the the poor
kids who died I don't think you should
have a platform to do that and endanger
their lives personally
um so I think there is a line and I
think he's going to get there with a
group of people which will be far more
rounded politically probably than the
than the current leadership group at
Twitter
no I totally agree with you I think
again Elon Musk is very good at picking
the right people to go to the right
places
um yeah hates a piece on Twitter should
not be there
um maybe a different point of view that
can be there you know for the first time
because
the problem with Twitter is that
they have
been just you know for the left
and they ban people who's on the right
like my case Shadow band I work I'm a
conservative I love this country they
will do everything to
uh limit my speech okay but that doesn't
happen on the left I mean they just
totally let it go I think what now with
Elon Musk taking over it's going to be a
lot much more
um well-balanced as far as
um uh who's on Twitter and what's what
would you I'm going to ask you I know
you don't want to talk about this in any
depth I completely understand why
because you have obviously a personal
connection here but uh Kanye you know
yay West who I interviewed last week
actually in the US you know there's a a
big debate about whether he should be
given social media platforms now so
setting aside your the fact you
obviously know him uh through the family
what's your view what's your view about
what he said and whether he should have
a platform
first of all any anti-semitic remarks
should be totally condemned by everybody
no matter if it's on Twitter or wherever
it is so that's where I stand as far as
um and that type of speech shouldn't be
around
yeah I that to me that is a line that if
that gets crossed that that should be it
um okay then it's great to talk to you I
love you coming on the show please come
back soon you always talk a lot of sense
and I really appreciate it it it's
always good to talk to you pierce thank
you